we're also so excited about karela de
Ville are we gonna get your version of
the song I don't know I'm not sure well
to wait and see we're right in the
middle of it right now so I'll pitch
your idea what's it like to wear that
black and white hair and the makeup in
the clothes it's pretty trippy it's uh
it's wild I mean right now I'm tired all
the time but uh there are times where
I'm like then I kind of wake up into it
and like this is bananas were you
obsessed with the Glenn Close one have
you talked to her about it at all on I
really I mean what I think she's
obviously the goat but I also just loved
the cartoon for a really long time so
yes she's incredible this is but this
comes before her story so this leads to
her to where she becomes true great it
doesn't it's a pleasure mr. bill what's
a pleasure yeah making your acquaintance
such a sweet thought I wish I could
reciprocate
Krewella isn't the only new project emma
is working on up next she's starring in
the zombie land sequel double tap you'll
be the first to die but I like your
enthusiasm you might die yeah thank you
for your sacrifice ten years later you
guys got the family back together how
does it really good yeah really good you
guys look like no time has passed honest
yeah well I mean time is definitely fast
I think it's clearest on abigail breslin
what do you eat 12 years like naughty
nobody will never age what he is like
the greatest advertisement for a vegan
healthy lifestyle that you've ever seen
if you look back at how this movie
changed your career the course of it or
influenced it what did it do um I don't
know I mean it's hard to sort of
quantify that it was just such a blast I
was 20 it was like such a great time in
life to get to meet all of these
wonderful people and we've all stayed so
tight ever since that it just it felt
like hanging out with my buddies I mean
even the director is like one of my
closest friends it was like such a fun
fun experience by the way if the zombie
apocalypse is real where are you running
first and why to a boat to go to an
island because I feel like it wouldn't
have spread to an island and I feel like
zombies aren't great swimmers you
thought about that yeah of course like
that would I was like why haven't we
done that in the
let's finish them oh yeah
[Music]